hello in this fire in this video I would
talk about DNA virus replication viruses
are very small non living organism there
even thousand times smaller than a
bacteria this image is just for you to
give an idea how small this virus
particles are and here's an example of
several viruses so once we classify
viruses we classify based on their
genetic materials I thought they are DNA
viruses which contains DNA as their
genetic material or they are RNA viruses
which has RNA as their genetic material
in this video I would talk about viruses
which has DNA as their genetic material
otherwise known as DNA viruses how they
replicate inside a host cell and
increase their number roughly they're
diverse in classes or families but the
overall way that they replicate inside a
host cell is quite similar imagine this
are some viruses which are infecting
some epithelial cells and this case is a
yellow epithelial cell is infected by
the virus so the first part is
absorption adsorption of the viral
particles on the surface of the cells
then secondly internalization of the
viral particle and the viral particle
bind to like a protein molecules on the
cell surface which allow their
internalization inside the cell and once
inside the cell it would shed off their
capsule and envelope and thereby
releasing the genetic material in this
case DNA inside the cytoplasm now the
genetic material would go inside the
nucleus and also using the host
machinery would first transcribe the
immediate early genes so it would first
transcribe the immediate early genes and
then immediate early gene products are
translated in the ear in the ER about
ribosomes now this immediate early gene
products have important function
immediate early gene
are used by the viral DNA to be
replicated so immediate early viral
genes help the viral DNA to get
replicated and then after while after
the replication late gene products are
transcribed and they are also translated
and sent didn't bear actually sent by
the cell into the Golgi bodies inside
the Golgi several capsid proteins
several envelope proteins etc etc are
produced so the viral particles are
produced inside the goal and then the
last step is the virus assembly so the
virus started assembling and once they
are assembled they are leaving the cell
the infected cell and they are ready to
infect another new host cell so this is
how our DNA virus DNA virus leaves
inside the host cell and infect the host
cell to amplify themselves and kill the
host cell preferably so that was my
video about DNA viruses if you liked my
video give it a quick thumbs up don't
forget to like share and subscribe thank